tous autant que nous sommes nous sommes
les enfants de l'océan
c'est bizarre mais c'est comme ça et il
y a une chose sur laquelle très peu de
gens tout le monde est d'accord en fait
toutes les toutes les sciences tout
l'effeuilleuse ofi toutes les religions
sont d'accord c'est que la vie est née
de l'eau c'est tout ça c'est ça a l'air
très simples sont des choses que tout le
monde connaît mais en fait quand on les
recadre dans notre siècle d'aujourd'hui
et dans notre corps est dans notre
pensée
ça prend une autre dimension nous sommes
vraiment des créatures aquatiques
nous sommes dans le ventre de nos mères
dans un océan agneaux tic l'âge de cette
semaine nous ressemblons exactement un
embryon de dauphin et donc nous naissons
vraiment on dit d'ailleurs la naissance
ça s'appelle perdre les eaux est en fait
c'est un peu ce qui nous arrive à nous
humains c'est à dire que est en venu de
l'océan
à un moment donné nous lui avons tourné
le dos il y a d'ailleurs un proverbe
hawaïen qui dit ne tourne jamais le dos
à l'océan
or nous humains qu'est ce qu'on a fait
on est sortis de l'océan et on est allé
sur terre c'était formidable ce monde
extraordinaire
on a commencé à développer des doigts
des mains à se relever quoi plutôt pour
cueillir les fruits à devenir des
bipèdes plutôt que des dauphins qui eux
sont restés dans l'océan et qui sont nos
frères
et donc cette action de s'éloigner de
plus en plus de l'océan à un moment
donné effectivement ça a fait que nous
n'étions plus en accord avec notre monde
71 % de cette planète
c'est l'océan imaginez-vous ce à deux
tiers de la planète
il ya plein de gens pour lesquels
l'océan n'a aucune existence
donc voila nous nous sommes détournées
de notre berceau de notre mère de notre
mère la mère le titre d'un de mes livres
mer-mer c'est pas un hasard et puis nous
sommes arrivés dans la civilisation et
au xxème siècle à peu près on a commencé
à reconquérir l'océan c'est à dire que
des gens se sont on a commencé à voir
des outils aussi et puis les gens se
sont vraiment immergé alors pourquoi on
sait pas émerger avant fin il
cordes et pop qui vont sous l'eau sans
aucun heurt attirail et bien en fait
curieusement vous savez aujourd'hui on
parle des plastiques pour l'océan les
plastiques c'est la mort de l'océan
c'est catastrophique et c'est censé
plastique il n'y aurait pas de conquête
de l'océan palmes masque tuba
ces trois petits outils de rien du tout
qui sont faits en plastique
évidemment eh bien ça a été une espèce
de baguette magique à sézanne
fantastique pour nous permettre d'aller
de découvrir cet élément qui était le
nôtre et auquel nous avions pendant des
siècles tourné le dos puisque quand vous
regardez bien notre histoire que ça soit
de la science la philosophie tout ça
l'océan est totalement absent il est
absent on est des créatures aquatiques
on vient de l'océan enocean est absent
de la philosophie même de l'art de la
culture de la science au programme
scolaire on devrait avoir haussé en os
et en océan en géographie en physique en
histoire et c'est l'océan et une place
prépondérante mais ça on l'a
complètement oubliée donc au xxème
siècle 10h des gens ont commencé à
reconquérir ce domaine alors certains
pionniers on connaît tous sauf un le
temps passe mais on connaît les gens qui
ont découvert le monde du silence comme
cousteau qui étaient là avec une caméra
surtout parce que cousteau c'était avant
tout un cinéaste
après ça on a des gens qui ont re
découvert le milieu de l'apnée par
exemple comme jacques mayol que j'ai eu
la chance de bien connaître et à qui on
avait dit que en dessous de 50 mètres sa
cage thoracique serait complètement
écrabouillé qu'il n'était pas question
qu'il fasse de l'apnée plus profond
jacques avec sa connaissance des
dauphins et du yoga et bien il a réussi
à descendre à 100 mètres à passer cette
barrière qui paraissait totalement
invraisemblable est infranchissable à
tout le monde
il est défendu à 100 m alors après il ya
aussi des gens qui ont choisi de partir
au tour du monde comme une autre
personne que j'ai eu l'honneur de bien
connaître d'être ami qui est bernard mas
tessier qui était un grand navigateur et
qui est le premier à avoir fait un tour
du monde en solitaire sans escale et
sans assistance
plus qu'un tour du monde même puisque au
moment de gagner la course
il est reparti dans l'autre sens il est
resté dix mois en mer voilà tout ça
c'était des exploits extraordinaires
qui faisait la une des journaux quand
jacques mayol et a plongé à 100 m ça a
été un événement fantastique mois
tessier qui qui fait un demi tour de
monde en plus événement fantastique
voilà donc tous ces gens y compris dans
le surf c'est à dire que dans les eaux
xxème siècle quelqu'un qui se refait une
vague de 9 10 m par exemple était
considéré comme un héros fantastiques
ça c'est la reconquête du 20e siècle et
cette reconquête elle va avec quelque
chose qui est que à bastien l'océan il
va pas si bien que ça il est pollué il
est sale il est malade et surtout le
problème numéro un de l'océan c'est la
surpêche
cette surpêche sauvages parfois pirates
qui fait que des bateaux venus d'un peu
partout beaucoup d'asie ravagé les fonds
marins et parfois il faut quand même
avoir conscience qu'on ne connaît on
connaît moins de 10 % de la biodiversité
marine
moins de 10% et on est en train
aujourd'hui de détruire des espèces
qu'on ne connaît pas qui peut être aurai
la clé de nos origines ou la clé de nos
problèmes plus tard
donc on air on à ce constat et on arrive
au 21ème siècle
aujourd'hui ce qui est fantastique
aujourd'hui c'est que on a une espèce
d'armes et pacifique de gens qui sont
passionnés par l'océan parce que
maintenant on a les outils on a vu des
gens surfent et on a vu des gens
naviguer et donc tout le monde on
devient un petit peu capable au point
que aujourd'hui un hasard et qui est une
ville à laquelle elle est jumelée la
ville de capbreton j'habite en surf des
vagues de 30 mètres alors qu'avant
c'était 8,9 m quand les gens qui font un
tour du monde en voilier en solitaire il
y en a tellement que ça passe totalement
inaperçu l'apnée aujourd'hui on est
plutôt dans les plus de 200 m en apnée
ce qui paraissait totalement impossible
tout cela pour vous dire que toutes ces
choses ont beaucoup évolué et que en
fait on a aujourd'hui ce comme je disais
une armée pacifique
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont capables de
naviguer de plongée de paix
ceux qui connaissent l'océan qui
connaissent les vagues j'appelle ça un
peu la génération waterman et ouaté
roumaine parce que il ya beaucoup de
femmes aussi qui viennent à l'océan tout
comme les hommes marc un plongeur
apnéiste exactement pareil je veux dire
les femmes ont même un rôle important à
jouer là-dedans
enfin bon c'est une autre histoire et
donc ce 21e siècle avec ces gens qui ont
des nouvelles capacités des nouveaux
outils puisque vous savez que
aujourd'hui on peut trouver des outils
pour tout faire sur l'océan pour plonger
il ya même des sous marins amateurs on
peut acheter un bateau des planches des
planches de surf de stand-up paddle
enfin bon là on appuie tout le monde a
accès à des combinaisons de plongée
parce que quand je quand je m'occupais
de l'océan quand je plongeais quand je
surfais dans les années 60 70
on n'avait pas de combinaison ça
n'existait pas donc ça c'était l'eau
froide c'était bien aussi etc voilà
aujourd'hui on a tous ces outils
extraordinaires qui nous permettent
vraiment de d'aller plus loin et donc ce
constat que parce que très souvent quand
je dis que je m'occupe de l'océan où
j'écris sur l'océan
ils ont dit aux régionales à cette
terrible 6 mais non l'océan c'est
magnifique
ah oui mais les poissons morts la
pollution les plastiques
alors moi je dis toujours ok ce constat
il est fait d'accord l'océan est pollué
il ya moins de poissons il ya beaucoup
de plastique malheureusement je peux pas
vous dire le contraire tout cela est
parfaitement vrai alors moi sur ce qui
ce qui là où je me suis intéressé c'est
de nous dire bon on a ce constat mais on
a des gens capables de faire des choses
et on a des gens qui font des choses un
peu partout sur la planète
donc j'ai voulu dans un livre qui
s'appelle demain l'océan demain
évidemment et en un clin d'oeil au
colibri des mères à scierie dion est un
un monde meilleur où la permaculture
serait une philosophie plus que du
jardinage et donc j'ai voulu connectés
comme un catalogue des ressources qui
existait dans les années 60-70 collecter
les bonnes nouvelles de l'océan alors
j'ai mis en exergue de mon livre de
citations qui en fait reflète ma
philosophie est la philosophie du livre
une citation c'est celle de voltaire qui
est très importante
j'ai décidé d'être heureux parce que
c'est bon pour la santé
il le savait déjà à l'époque et on peut
décider d'être heureux les autres
citations et de catherine chabaud une
très grande navigatrice qui dit
s'attaquer aux solutions plutôt qu'aux
problèmes et quand on mélange c'est deux
choses là c'est à dire une espèce
d'optimisme de convictions idéologiques
plus s'attaquer aux solutions
eh bien on arrive à des résultats
fantastiques
donc j'ai voulu moi repérez un peu
toutes les initiatives dans la planète
grandes ou petites qui sont bonnes pour
l'océan et je dois dire que j'ai été
surpris parce que il y en avait beaucoup
beaucoup plus que je n'osais l'imaginé
donc ça c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle de savoir qu'on ne peut plus
comptabiliser les initiatives positives
alors vous allez me dire oui mais quel
genre d'initiatives positives
alors aujourd'hui on construit des
bateaux hybrides qui vont fonctionner
avec le solaire l'hydrogène et même il
ya un bateau qui avait construit qui va
aspirer les plastiques pour en faire un
carburant donc ça c'est expérimental
mais ça va avoir lieu
et alors en ce qui concerne les
plastiques vous en dira oui les
plastiques les plastiques
alors y'a un jeune homme qui il ya une
dizaine d'années a fait un petit et
dicks en hollande avec 40 copains autour
il s'appelait il s'appelle boyan slat il
avait 18 ans et ils y croyaient qu à
moitié il avait une idée qui était de
barrer les plastiques pour les empêcher
de pour les récupérer et puis au bout
d'un mois deux mois il a reçu énormément
d'argent sur son compte
aujourd'hui il a récolté 36 millions de
dollars et il a mis au point des espèces
de barrières flottantes qui permettent
de récupérer les plastiques
alors ça veut dire oui mais c'est comme
d'avoir une louche dans la mer etc
or on a des chiffres qui sont sortis
récemment qu'ils nous disent que 86% des
plastiques qui viennent par les cours
d'eau viennent de seulement 10 fleuve
dans le monde qui sont entre l'asie la
russie l'afrique est donc si on pouvait
utiliser cette technique de brian slat
dans des estuaires
à ce moment là on empêche les maquereaux
plastique de devenir des micro
plastiques ce qui est vraiment un
problème
donc ce qu'il était en train de faire
c'est formidable autre chose les
énergies marines renouvelables en france
en france on est extra
en retard sur les énergies marines
renouvelables sans doute parce qu'on a
un gros gros lobby nucléaire
n'empêche que les expériences qui sont
faites sur les éoliennes offshore qui
sont plantées dans le sol sont
incroyables c'est à dire qu'elles
fournissent 30% de plus d'énergie que
les éoliennes à terre et en plus on
s'aperçoit que ça crée des espèces de
sanctuaires marins parce que ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que l'océan
heureusement une capacité de résilience
extraordinaire et bien autour de ces
éoliennes on trouve des moules qui ont
attiré des crustacés qui ont tiré des
poissons qui ont attiré des mammifères
est là aujourd'hui on a une population
de phoques extraordinaire autour des
éoliennes qui s'épanouit complètement là
bas donc voyez des solutions existent et
ça c'est plutôt des bonnes nouvelles
mais surtout la langue le plus important
ce sont les sciences participatives
alors le temps va me manquer pour vous
expliquer vous donner des exemples les
sciences participatives permettent à
tous passionnés de l'océan muni d'un
smartphone ou munis d'un ordinateur de
renvoyer des informations aux
scientifiques
donc tous les gens qui sont passionnés
qui ont un voilier une planche de surf
qui vont même en apnée peuvent faire des
tas de choses les plongeurs aujourd'hui
on leur demande de dalles et sur les
récifs de regarder d'observer et de
rapporter des informations on peut aussi
demander aux gens sur les sur leur
ordinateur de surveiller la pêche
illégale
la fondation leonardo dicaprio et google
ont mis au point des algorithmes très
complexe qui vous permette à tout à
chacun de surveiller les battle heroes
celui-là il est rentré dans un
sanctuaire hop on appuie et sa part le
bateau est intercepté tout ça commence à
se mettre en place
même ifremer à faire des programmes qui
permettent
c'est une espèce de shazam de l'océan
donc on peut si on trouve quelque chose
sur sur la grève ou un poisson vous avez
la possibilité de savoir ce que c'est et
si c'est quelque chose qu'on connaît pas
et bien les justement les scientifiques
s'en servent donc voyez tout ça c'est
quand même des très très bonne nouvelle
et l'autre dimension que je voudrais
faire passer ce soit en dehors du fait
que voilà on assez science participative
on a tous ces gens qui peuvent
aujourd'hui agir pour l'océan
parce que souvent les gens me disent
mais moi j'aime le son mais qu'est-ce
que je peux faire
sous-entendu c'est tellement immense
alors c'est tellement immense l'océan
que
la haute mer ce qu'on appelle la haute
mer c'est un espace qui n'appartient à
personne en dehors des eaux
territoriales et bien la haute mer
représente 45 % de notre planète
non il faut rentrer ces chiffres là dans
la tête c'est à dire que presque la
moitié de notre planète n'appartient à
personne donc à tout le monde et que
c'est un effet alors évidemment c'est un
espace qu'il faut protéger protéger
protéger
d'autant plus que ma conviction et les
je ne suis pas le seul c'est que il y a
dans l'océan une véritable dimension
spirituelle et ce dernier point pour moi
c'est celui qui compte le plus c'est à
dire que plus je me baigne plus je vais
dans les vagues plus j'ai une espèce de
communication très forte avec l'océan
comme un être sensible qui comprend
qui sait et en fait la mémoire du monde
eh bien elle est dans l'océan il y à un
universitaire japonais qui s'appelle
masaru emoto et qui a fait des
expériences sur les gouttes d'eau la
structure moléculaire des gouttes d'eau
à travers la cristallisation sensible on
peut voir la structure moléculaire il a
exposé certaines goutte d'eau certains
bocaux à des vibrations tout à fait
positive je vous aime je prie pour vous
et c'est hélas les structures deviennent
magnifique comme des mandalas
fantastique
après quand on expose les gouttes d'eau
à des vibrations au style genre ouais je
te déteste et moche et c'est au bout
d'un certain temps on observe la
structure moléculaire on voit qu'elle
est complètement difformes et nous
qu'est ce qu'on est
on est des océans on est des outre on
est plein de flotte
notre cerveau c'est 80% de lure notre
corps est à une représentation de
l'océan
notre sens à la même salinité que l'eau
de mer de même que nos larmes
donc imaginez un peu ça veut dire que on
est aussi on sent les on sent les marais
on sent les tempêtes on sent les basses
pressions et on sent les bonnes
vibrations
c'est ce que j'appelle la permaculture
en tant que philosophie humaine quand on
est bien entouré
on fait des bonnes choses et l' inverse
malheureusement est vrai aussi
donc quand on met tout ça ensemble eh
bien on se dit voilà notre berceau ce
qui a fait de nous
des humains l'océan c'est le moment de
s'en occuper vraiment et pour moi les
deux mots clés de notre vie en tant
qu'humain ces lots et l'amour c'est à
dire que si on a ces deux choses que les
dauphins pratique très très bien vous
savez on dit vivre d'amour et d'eau
fraîche salaire un peu rigolo comme ça
mais en fait si on a ces deux éléments
si on a l'eau et l'amour en fait on peut
vraiment créer une nouvelle
une nouvelle vie une nouvelle forme
d'existence et c'est pour ça que je dis
que nous avons aujourd'hui besoin de
l'océan qui nous n'avons jamais autant
eu besoin de l'océan qu'aujourd'hui est
lui vraiment besoin de nous aussi et
donc l'océanisation de l'humanité ce que
j'appelle l'océanisation d'humanité donc
c'est ce mouvement de nouveau vers
l'océan et c'est plus que quelque chose
qu'on peut faire par conviction c'est
une nécessité absolue pour que nous
redevenions des êtres humains complet
[Applaudissements]